la lumière de la meilleure actrice est
au début et à noémie merlan normale ont
fait le tour du monde avec cette romance
interdite xviiie siècle avec l'arrêt
chez nos confrères golden globes
adoré par la presse internationale
sortie aux états unis le film aborde sur
le sujet brûlant du moment en fine des
femmes fait par une femme
noémie merlan donc distingué par les
journalistes étrangers qui avaient déjà
été repérés dans les héritiers de marie
castille mention schaar bravo noémie
merlan pressant à tous
merci merci à l'académie des lumières
pour ce prix ça me touche énormément
ce film a commencé pour moi par un
regard pendant le casting un regard que
je n'oublierai jamais regard
bienveillant un regard ou horizontal un
regard intense celui de céline qui mme
hakima qui m'a accompagné dès le début
jusqu'à jusqu'à maintenant pour pour
trouver ce rôle de marianne et et bien
plus merci aussi à adel adèle je
t'admire tellement merci pour pour cette
danse qu'on a partagé ensemble
merci pour ta générosité merci pour pour
ta force ta liberté
merci à tous et regarde où christelle
barras bénédicte couvreur clair matin
loana bages rami valeria golino toute
l'équipe du film
merci à mon agent grégory veille le
merci à mes parents ce film circule
partout se partagent sans doute parce
qu'il évoque un manque celui de nos
imaginaires à nous les femmes
alors j'espère que ce mouvement ne fait
que commencer
merci et encore merci beaucoup
ok